this video is kindly sponsored by
hellofresh
find out more later in the video hey 42
here
consider for a moment the modern day
city of liverpool
the 10th largest city in england by
primary urban area
with a busy international port
now imagine if i told you that in 200
years
liverpool would be almost entirely
underwater
don't worry if you're a merseysider you
aren't going to wake up tomorrow and see
sharks circling the liver building well
you might do one day
but more on that later however this was
the exact
watery fate of the bustling medieval
town
of dunwich like liverpool today in the
11th century
dunwich was england's 10th largest city
like liverpool it was a busy commercial
port with ships coming and going
to and from multiple continents
by the end of the 13th century this
prosperous
international city had almost entirely
disappeared today dunich's population
is a tiny 183 and visitors are greeted
by
a couple of streets a handful of houses
a windswept beach
a single pub and a museum that tells the
town's woeful tale
you see dunwich is the town
that drowned no matter what's going on
in the world
everyone needs to eat that's why
hellofresh is here to make eating
better and easier by eliminating the
dreaded grocery
shop and stressful meal planning
hellofresh makes cooking at home
fun and easy by delivering everything
you need
to prepare wholesome delicious meals
right to your door
hello fresh recipes are so delicious
every recipe is packed with high quality
fresh produce sourced directly from
farmers
they have a huge selection of recipes
with more five star choices than any
other meal kit
i especially enjoyed the chicken laxa
and the roast chicken with vegetables
hello fresh saves you time and stress
i'm guilty of working endless hours and
i can easily let time slip away from me
so it was honestly so refreshing and
relaxing
to know my dinner was solved the recipes
were super easy to follow and
wrap it to prepare and cook hellofresh
is flexible
you can easily change your delivery days
or food preferences
their meals are healthy and fulfilling
and you can add extras to your delivery
such as quick lunches
extra proteins or their yummy garlic
bread
personally i loved having hello fresh in
my life when i tried it it was
easy healthy and delicious and i
couldn't wait for dinner each night
and i know you'll love it too so if you
want to experience just how great
hellofresh is
head to hellofresh.com and use code 4212
to get 12 free meals including free
shipping
to understand just how important dunnich
was in its heyday
let's take a brisk stroll down
anglo-saxon history late
because before the end of the 10th
century 927
a.d to be precise england as a
nation didn't really exist instead it
was a patchwork of
independent kingdoms which were often at
war
either with each other or against viking
invaders
an anglo-saxon from dorset on the south
coast
wouldn't recognize someone from durham
in the north
as being of the same nation whilst they
shared the anglo-saxon language
their dialects were so different that
communication would have involved a lot
of guesswork
and grunts there were seven main
anglo-saxon kingdoms
northumbria stretched from the scottish
border all the way down to the midlands
from there mercia encompassed the entire
midlands
down to london then the southern
kingdoms were divided between
wessex in the you guessed it
west kent and essex in the
east and finally there was the kingdom
of the east angles
or east anglia and so we returned to
england's lost city dunwich with a
population of 4500
was east anglia's largest port and the
kingdom's
capital city it rivaled london both in
size
and importance even after effelstan
united the kingdoms to create
england in 927 a.d
dunich retained its importance in fact
it was granted a royal charter in 1199
which gave it an official governmental
structure
with magistrates bailiffs and a coroner
the etymology of the city's name gives
us an interesting insight
into its importance as a center of
commerce the sharpest amongst you will
have noticed dunnich
has a w in it and you may therefore
presume
i am rather typically pronouncing it
with all the elegance
of a drunk ape but in fact the witch
suffix in english place names comes from
the old english word
wic which was confusingly pronounced
witch and it meant trading center
or harbour so if you ever see
the witch suffix you can probably assume
that place was an important center of
trade
like dunwich as for why the w is now
silent
well that's just because us english are
lazy gits
and due to a linguistic process known as
elision
it was dropped from normal conversation
over time
to make it easier to pronounce so then
what passed through dunich's busy port
local wool and grain would have been the
primary exports
whilst imports consisted mostly of
luxuries from the continent
including french wine and flemish fabric
but donatch's trade routes extended as
far as the middle east
bitumen found at the famous sutton who
7th century burial site
around 20 miles from dunwich has been
shown to be
of syrian origin and spices
particularly pepper were surprisingly
common in anglo-saxon cuisine
at least for the wealthy and this exotic
delicacy
very likely graced the ports of dunwich
dunich was also home to a busy fishing
fleet
with unimpeded access to the plentiful
north sea
while some of the town's boats were
relegated to seeking sprats
and herring in local fishing grounds
others would have traveled as far
as iceland as a seafaring town dudach
was also a center of shipbuilding
whilst many of the ships built and done
it would have been trade or fishing
vessels
warships were also constructed in its
harbour
boats built in donate would have been
used in epic saxon and viking battles in
the north sea
with the town's harbour itself being an
essential cog
in the realm's coastal defenses in 1229
king henry iii ordered 40 warships to be
built in dunwich as he put it
well equipped with all kinds of armament
which
in 1230 constituted a large portion of
the fleet
that left from portsmouth and travelled
to attack france under his leadership
if you visit donetsk today you can see
the remains of a leper hospital
along with the ruins of greyfire's
monastery
the last of the town's churches fell off
the edge of the cliff and into the sea
in 1919
and it's said that if you sit on dunwich
beach
at low tide and listen carefully you'll
hear
dunwich's church bells ringing from
beneath the waves
but today there's much more than just
an old rusty bell beneath the sea in
these parts
in fact there's a whole city
that prosperous medieval city i just
described
well it now sits at the bottom of the
north sea
all of it which has caused many to
name donatch britain's atlantis
because you know what us british are
like we've got to have a little version
of bloody everything
but this begs the question how did such
a large
for the day and important city become
little more than an
artificial coral reef it began gradually
with dunich's impressive natural harbour
being slowly buffeted
and battered by the brutal north sea
waves
even while stunning was growing fast and
building ships to send out across the
world
it was already beginning to sink
according to the doomsday book
half of donations farmland was taken by
the waves
in the short 20 years between 1066
and 1086 even in its heyday
the writing was already on the wall for
dunwich
we know that the coast along the stretch
of suffolk where the remains of dunwich
now sit
erodes at around a metre a year don't
think that sounds like much
well it means that the shoreline now
lies around
two kilometers further inland than it
did in roman times
that's about the length of london's
oxford street
all this means that by the 13th century
the north sea was already encroaching
quite
seriously on dunwich at the same time
however the people of dunwich believed
they could defend it
they did after all have a town that was
more than worth defending
of national and even international
importance
just as london liverpool hull and other
port cities today
protect themselves with sea defenses so
did dunwich
but the scrabble to stay above water got
increasingly difficult
and desperate with houses already
standing
right on the cliff's edge you see dunich
was not suffering
simply from normal coastal erosion
the natural harbour that had bought the
town all its prosperity
was partly created by king's home
a sand and shingle spit that ran for
around four kilometers
as this moved along the coast and
eventually disappeared so the sea
channels that linked
harbour river and sea began to disappear
too and with them dunich's natural
harbour
throughout the 13th century sea walls
were built
and then breached and then rebuilt as
the town of dunwich came under ever
greater attack
from the forces of nature in 1250
a large storm and unusually high tide
moved the king's home spit and diverted
the river blithe this was a big problem
ships departing dunwich used this river
to sail out to sea
no longer able to do so the people have
done it
keen to protect their livelihoods
laboriously
dug a new channel out to sea
sadly that hard work was all but wasted
just 36 years later in 1286
many of those who built that channel
would still have been alive to witness
dunwich's fate
all but sealed another viciously high
tide
and a strong easterly storm devastated
the town
not only did the sea water flood through
its streets houses
and churches it took a chunk of the town
with it
a strip of land around 100 metres wide
was carried off into the north sea
in 1328 there was yet another brutal
storm
that's all but ended dunwich both as a
town
and as a port two monasteries were
almost
totally swept into the sea along with
numerous houses
and it didn't just lose houses the
king's home spit
moved again completely blocking
dunnich's
already dying harbour with no
easy access for boats dunwich's entire
reason for being was no more
and no income from the harbors toll
booth
meant no money for any more fruitless
attempts
at building sea walls and defenses
and thus stunning became a shadow of its
former glory
sitting solemnly along the battered
coast just
waiting to die and
with every storm more of it did
in 1347 400 houses
and two churches were swept away as each
chunk of cliff fell into the sea it took
with it
parts of dunwich and its history with
each disappearing churchyard
the bones of people buried there could
be seen sticking out of the cliff
this once prosperous capital city
was fast turning into an open-air
cemetery
dutch's disappearance continued though
stubborn dunwiches continue to live
there
despite the apparently constant risk of
suddenly
drowning and the lack of any obvious
industry to replace its one's bustling
port
it's even thought that new houses were
built in dunwich
just as parts of it continue to fall off
the cliff edge
a 1587 map shows dunnage as half the
size it was in 1200
but it also shows new buildings
that weren't part of the medieval town
you have to admire the tenacity of its
residents to have a sea view
by the 20th century the entirety of the
once
thriving international medieval port of
dunwich
had sunk into the sea all that's left
today of the medieval town are
a few ruined sections of the leper
hospital because it was built
deliberately away from the town centre
and one of its monasteries which was
built in the late 13th century
to replace an earlier building that had
been taken by the sea
only divers ever get close to seeing
anything more of medieval donatch
and doing that is a difficult and
dangerous task
stuart bacon marine archaeologist and
director of the suffolk underwater
studies unit
has been diving into donations murky
waters
since 1971. even though much of the town
is just a few meters under the surface
it's rare that he and his team of divers
can see anything at all in one thousand
dives bacon has only seen further than a
meter
a handful of times on most dives
he can see just one or two centimeters
exploring the underwater town not
through sight
but by touch we know that dunwich is
lost to the waves
no doubt the few streets it has left
will join the rest of the town under the
water
in just a few decades time but will
there be
another dunwich another town
disappearing entirely
yes almost certainly much of eastern
england's coast is constantly eroding
it's one of the fastest eroding
coastlines in europe and
as in 14th century dunwich there are
constant debates
about what we should do about it sea
defenses are usually erected
and then breached and then shored up
again at great expense
yet houses still fall into the sea in
december 2013
a tidal surge and hurricane force winds
caused floods along the whole of
england's eastern coast
at hemsby in norfolk seven houses fell
dramatically and suddenly down the cliff
to be claimed by the sea
other villages along the east anglian
coast have already disappeared
completely
such as eccles on sea in norfolk which
was abandoned in the 17th century
eastern bavants just a couple of miles
north of dunwich
has almost entirely disappeared in
hayesburg
in norfolk there's another why the holy
piss is that pronounced like that
word for you water pipes that once ran
to houses
now protrude out from the cliffs and the
road to the coast
now stops at a broken cliff edge the
reality is that
there's not much we can do to stop this
happening we might be able to show up
defenses in bigger towns for a while
but experts agree that trying to save
everywhere
indefinitely is impossible we still
don't know
how much of this erosion we can blame on
climate change and rising sea levels
or perhaps it's just the natural
symphony of storm damage
which is as old as the earth itself but
there is one thing we know
when the seed decides it doesn't like a
piece of land and wants to remodel
there's little we can do to stop it
let's for a moment
look back way beyond the medieval period
to the stone age
donetch then would have been the upper
edge of a vast area of land
that stretched from east anglia to the
netherlands
known as doggerland if you've ever got
so bleeding bored that you've listened
to the shipping forecast
you might have heard that name this now
drowned world was
once a gentle landscape of rolling hills
woodlands and swamps where nomadic
tribes roamed
hunted and fished alongside a few
wandering
mammoths fishing trawlers still
regularly bring up stone age tools
and ancient mammoth bones from the sea
floor in a net full of cod
in 2015 divers found the remains of a
submerged forest
in the sea off the coast of norfolk so
really it isn't dunwich that's britain's
atlantis
it's doggerland doggerland was gradually
flooded at the end of the last ice age
around 6500 bc as ice sheets and
glaciers flooded its low-lying plains
its tribes were forced to higher ground
some of them
no doubt ended up near dunwich it's also
thought that a huge tsunami caused by a
landslide in the norwegian sea
may have sealed the deal and submerged
duggar land forever
any stone age doggerlanders who hadn't
already run for safety
were done for and it might be that
there's not that much we can do to stop
even more of our land going the same way
as dunwich and doggerland even cities
that
like dunwich have put time money and
effort into
sea defenses might just be on very
expensive
borrowed time the east yorkshire city of
hull
will by some predictions be completely
underwater
by 2050 maybe 20 40 if we're lucky
in 2007 large parts of the city were
evacuated after floods
and in 2013 the city's main sea defense
was just centimeters away from being
breached
and it's not just hull the same fate
might be waiting for large parts of
norfolk and suffolk coasts
and the cambridge defense further afield
large parts of the netherlands denmark
and belgium could be swept away
within the next 30 years and perhaps
in as little as a few decades from now
there could be many more
churches ringing their ghostly bells
from beneath the waves
thanks for watching